Now, another key feature that we have heard
from developers that they want access to in
the browser is the camera.
Here, for examples the Buzz Web application.
We'd love to not only post a Buzz but we would
love to be able to include a picture. How
do you access the camera from the Web browser?
In this development build we built those APIs
right into the Web browser such that Matt
can now simply select, if he wants to -- and
it looks like in this case this demo is not
going to work. We will give it one shot, and
we will move on if it doesn't work -- but
you can access that camera capability right
from within the browser.
And we will show you that in the sandbox later.
It's great.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let's talk about another capability
that's available.
But before we talk about that capability,
let me remind you of what's possible in Android.
Google, starting about several years ago,
really made a deep investment in voice recognition.
We recognized that the mobile device, because
of its limited input capability, would be
the platform in which people used voice input
more than any other platform.
In fact, we see a stunning number of queries
being done on mobile devices where the input
is a human voice.
Now, just as a reminder of how fantastic our
capability has become over the past two years,
let me do a few demos. Or more accurately,
Matt, why don't you highlight a few cases.
>>Matt: Pictures of Barack Obama with the
French President at the G8 summit.
>>Vic Gundotra: That's a tough one. Boom!
Look at that!
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Because this is so fun, let's
do a few more.
>>Matt: Pictures of the Golden Gate Bridge
at sunset.
>>Vic Gundotra: These are queries you are
likely not to type in let alone get a response
back in a few seconds. Isn't that great?
And one more.
[ Applause ]
>>Matt: Del Dotto Vineyards, Napa.
>>Vic Gundotra: My favorite vineyard in Napa.
Boom.
What Matt just showed you was phenomenal voice
recognition that we are now shipping in Japanese,
English, a number of languages, and that's
constantly increasing, but what is coming
next is the also the ability to understand
human intentions. We will give you a very
simple sneak peek at the kinds of things we
are going to enable.
>>Matt: Call fifth floor restaurant.
>>Vic Gundotra: So in this case, because he
said "call," it got a trigger. And there are
many, many more intentions we are going to
build in and make it very, very simple for
to you use voice input as a first class way
to interact with your Android device.
>>Matt: Vic, we have got it.
>>Vic Gundotra: Let's go back to the camera
and see if this thing works. This is a Web
app. It's a Buzz Web app. There is the camera.
From the browser, boom! Right into the camera.
Isn't that great? And now you can post a picture
and give Web developers the same type of capabilities
you would expect in a native application.
Glad that worked. No need for you guys to
visit the sandbox.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Getting back to the speech
demonstration, what we showed you was capability
that we make available to developers, but
what about accessing that capability from
the browser? Here is a Web app.
It is a translate app from Google with one
new feature. You will note the microphone
right there at the top. Matt, if you could
just point to the microphone. There it is.
And watch what Matt does.
>>Matt: Can you help me find the nearest hospital?
>>> (repeating in French).
>>Vic Gundotra: Awesome! Awesome!
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right. Let's go back to
slides.
Now, we're not only committed to making sure
that Android -- You can clap. I will let you
clap.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You know, I love it when I
don't even have to speak to a slide and we
just get applause.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: I am so tempted to go on.
But let me just make a point here. We are
not only committed to having the world's fastest
browser. We're committed to having the world's
most comprehensive browser.
It turns out that on the Internet, people
use Flash!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And part of being open means
you are inclusive, rather than exclusive.
And you are open to innovation.
You know, this was driven home to me very
powerfully when my daughter picked up my iPad
and went to her favorite Web site, Web site
nickelodeon, and this is what she saw on the
iPad.
Can we switch to the iPad? A sea of orange!
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: She said, "Daddy, can I play
with your Android device?" And this is what
she saw.
The full nickelodeon site. Isn't that great?
That's what openness means.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And by the way, a special
thanks to Adobe for their incredible willingness
to work with us, engage with us on Android
and in chrome and in many other areas. It's
really fun to work with other folks in the
ecosystem to meet the needs of users.
Much nicer than just saying no.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right. Let's go back to
slides.
Now, we have also made significant improvements
in the Android Marketplace.
We listened carefully to the feedback we have
gotten from developers and from users, and
I think you are going to like the enhancements.
Let's talk about what we have done on average,
our data shows that our users are installing
more than 40 apps on their Android device,
so finding those apps is a challenge. Also
they want to search within the data of those
apps, they want to move those apps to the
SD card, and they want to update all without
having to update each individual app by themselves.
Let me show you through a series of demos
what we have done here. Let's go to demos.
The first demonstration we are going to show
you is just searching the apps. Now with the
Quick Search box we make it trivially easy
to scope it to apps. As soon as you start
typing a letter, the app you are looking for
just comes up.
It's a simple and easy way to go find apps.
Not only can you find apps, but we have improved
the Quick Search box so developers can plug
into the search framework. In that case that
icon is for Mint. Mint is a financial application,
and now you are searching within the data
of that application bringing up your financial
records.
We think developers are going to extend this
in all sorts of exciting ways, making not
only Android more usable, but their own applications
be surface, discoverable, and more fun and
engaging for the user.
Another issue we have heard is people want
to take advantage of the openness of Android,
the ability for you to plug in an SD card
with arbitrary amounts of memory. And they
want to move apps not just in the internal
memory but off to the SD card.
Two points. We've enabled that capability
in a secure way with Froyo, but we have also
made it so the user never has to worry about
it. When they install an application, we will
intelligently look at the space and if appropriate,
move it to the SD card. If the user wants
to get involved and manually move things around,
that's what this demonstration shows. In this
case, Matt is going to take a brand-new game,
Need for Speed, and he is going to shift that
game from the internal memory onto the SD
card. There you go. The whole 50 megabytes
is being moved over. Why don't we just start
the game. Why don't you launch that game.
You can see it's on the SD card.
Why don't you launch that game.
Isn't that awesome? Great new game, Need for
Speed, and it can live on your SD card.
Okay. Let's move on.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Matt, Matt, we have got to
go. I know the game is fun.
All right. Let's go into the marketplace and
talk about....
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right. Let's talk about
update all functionality.
Matt, that's you.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: He is easily distracted.
All right. Today, you have to update each
application individually. In Froyo, we have
made it simple. At the bottom of the Android
Marketplace you see the update all button.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: I am kind of embarrassed you
have to clap on that. We're glad it's there.
We have gone one step further with Froyo.
Why should the user have to take any action?
Starting with Froyo, with the user's permission
you can allow automatic updating, and all
your apps are updated all the time. Isn't
that great?
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And the user doesn't have
to worry about this at all.
Let's go back to slides.
Another key feature we're adding in Froyo
is designed to meet the needs of developers.
We want the best apps on Android, the highest
quality apps. And that means we need to close
the loop when there's a problem.